we flew him all the way out from
australia
it's the ufc champion alexander
volkonovsky and i'm phenom venezuelan
arepas out of the back of an el camino
on this week's food truck diaries let's
go
[Music]
what's up brother oh not for much mate
just uh soaking up the victory on a bit
of a victory tour yeah you're on a
victory tour man all the way from
freaking australia fancy seeing you here
man you're the only guy that i don't
work on sundays that's my thing a lot of
comics work on sundays i'm sure other
people in business work on sundays i
don't work sunday especially easter
sunday oh yeah and then they told me
they're like dude he leaves tonight so
if we're going to do it because i was on
tour so i couldn't do it any other day
like anything you can do with sunday
like oh man except to call my girl i was
like i know we get the kids for easter
and the bunnies and [ __ ] but uh yeah i
got to do food truck i go work babe oh i
feel bad now you shouldn't though you
shouldn't though because i thought she's
latina so i gotta be careful you know i
gotta be easy because i don't know if
you have latinas in australia but
they're yeah they're [ __ ] spicy too
they're tough to navigate but you're one
of her favorite fighters when i told her
you were coming out she was oh that's
cool
i'm like chill chill put your titties
back and chill
but it's good to see me i appreciate you
doing this no no rosemary thanks for
having me and again sorry for the for
the days but yeah we leave tonight so no
i mean dude this is great man have you
uh
you know do you do you feel pressure now
that i think they get you ranked number
two pound for pound on you know in the
world which is nuts do you feel any type
of pressure to get out and like kind of
i don't know kind of raise your status a
little bit do you feel that pressure i
don't know i don't know if it's a
pressure man i'll look bean champ
through
how it has been in australia through all
the lockdowns and all that it's been
it's been a little tough i haven't been
able to do this yeah you know because
i've got to go you know you have to go
home do your two-week quarantine you
guys were involved it was yeah man it
was a yeah it was obviously tough
forever but i mean it was i couldn't
really do it so right now soaking it up
i don't mind yeah i mean a lot of people
are like oh did you get over the meat i
i don't i enjoy it because i haven't
really had you know i can show off the
belt a little bit have a good chat to
you guys you know have a bit of banner
good good time so i don't mind i don't
mind i'm real look i'm ready to go home
but at the same time i enjoyed this
whole process and yeah like i said i
haven't had a chance to really do it
yeah i think it's important to do but i
also feel like the ufc has changed a
little bit and i think it's a little bit
of the conor mcgregor effect because
it was in his nature to be so
entertaining outlandish kind of even
bigger than just fighting side octagon
and people saw
the income and the notoriety that that
brought so a lot of fires like oh that's
what i have to do
but it's not it's really unless it's in
your nature to do that you don't have to
do that man you know you look at khabib
massive stuff yeah massive and he he
didn't he was really humble and just put
in work and i'm not saying you're like
khabib because you're definitely you
know obviously way better at english but
also like you know you destroy guys and
people like to see it and then you're
also you know you have an interesting
story so i think you know as far as the
entertainment side you don't have to go
too far over like you don't have to try
because you're entertaining but it's
more about like just you doing it
because you don't do it a lot that's why
because you're in australia so when they
told me you're in l.a i'm like i gotta
make it happen man yeah when's the next
time the champs can be out here although
like you gotta you gotta remember as
well who do people uh really remember
the best you know the best the best of
what you do and uh
again it's a
it's a early days you know i'm from
australia and things like that but i
mean at the same time you know obviously
people are you're really jumping on
board and things are really moving now
and it's only earlier for me so yeah i'm
playing on big things massive things
this year and uh yeah man it's good like
i said it just uh to be able to do what
i'm doing it's good but i'm gonna keep
going out there improve and as i say
i'll raise the bar every time i go there
next time you see me last time man i'm
telling you i'm gonna raise the bar
again next time i feel like it's been a
slow maybe just me you know i'm uh i i'm
not uh you know i i wouldn't say i take
a while to jump on somebody's train but
i guess with you
fan i knew you're a monster
and then i feel like even in the general
pipe like public like it took it was
like kind of a slow boil before
everyone's like oh yeah he's one of the
best we have by far it was like this
weird slow boil and tell me if i'm
completely off on this i think a little
bit of your
i don't say delay of your super stardom
happened because of the max holloway
stuff i think max holloway i'll be very
up front max always a buddy man i love
max yeah love you yeah yeah yeah
hopefully i don't want you guys to fight
now that i know both of you but i love
max and i think
everybody loves max yeah he's beloved
he's a fan favorite a nice guy a dad
he's such a good dude
and then when you fought him and the
first time and took the belt it just
you know it's the mma you know fan base
you just kind of got this i don't hate
or dislike that wasn't warranted because
you out there you know i don't make the
[ __ ] decision maybe i fight the guy i
won the fight what do you want me to do
and then you get the second fight and
it's a split decision and then you have
like dana and big john who were like oh
we thought it went the other way so i
feel like that kind of delayed this
australian rocket ship that you're on
and then now you go out there and what
you did uh brian ortega which is you
know fight of the year one of the best
fights i've ever seen and again or i
quit
saying everybody's my friend but brian
ortega and i are super close oh we're
training together really close and he's
a monster for you to get out of that
guillotine is legendary because i've
seen him put away
the the baddest of black belts with that
guillotine and for you i i was literally
standing up in my chair going oh he's
[ __ ] oh it's over and he got out of it
which and i was like oh he's a complete
badass so i think the brian ortega fight
the fan base like oh he's the real deal
because you know it was a great fight
fight of the year and then with korean
zombie you know it's the best form
you've ever been in so now it's just
it's kind of like your time yeah man
look
it's just it's a timing thing as well
you go back and you look uh through
history and some of the other champions
a lot of them still are going to going
to have that problem as well like you
know people are just getting to
understand them you know what does you
know especially when you've had big
champions before them and you you take a
build off a big champion yeah some
people are going to be a bit of a
feeling especially if you're from
australia it's like only source you're
going to you
so it's just that's just how it is but
you know everyone's obviously jumping on
board and yeah they are uh but i mean
look and again yeah max is a a cool dude
he's a chill dude people love him you
know i know you guys don't really talk
[ __ ] yeah you guys don't need to i don't
need that from you it was even a it's
funny you talk about that if you
remember the situation he was in it's
pretty similar like it took him a long
time for people to
get the respect you know even get a
title fight hundred percent like 10 11.
before he could even fight yeah for the
title and people kept doubting him and
all that and then he just shut them all
up proved them all wrong and then people
like
oh yeah this school yeah he was himself
the whole way through yeah people loved
that yeah they just needed a bit of time
to to get used to that and that's sort
of where i am now and people are
starting to get used to it and yeah
people love it i told you coming on the
show i'm getting the people are crank
for it man yeah they love you what's it
like and then uh sky's the limit so i
look up and i'm expecting to do even
bigger things and it's just it's gonna
roll on when you when you talk about
bigger things you talk about what's next
after you have that fight against korean
zombie where you completely outclassed
them and i think it shows your character
i don't know if some people got mad at
or whatever online and i think it was
the fourth round when he came he
answered the bell and then you go you
sure yeah i thought that was you
being human going dude you do you don't
you don't need to keep doing this man
trust me you ain't gonna win this fight
dude yeah and i i think a it shows your
character shows how good of a person you
are which only wants you more fans then
b
we have an issue in mma because his
coroner should never let him go out
there for the fourth round which is an
issue in our sport in general yeah well
that's a that's what it was it was there
obviously no disrespect no i think what
i said i said to him um are you all
right or something like a
like you want to keep doing this like
you know what i mean like yeah that was
weird like what i expect him to say
anyway i don't know why i said it but
that was really me like come on man
because i i sort of knew that he was
done i could see that he was defeated in
what round well in that after the third
yeah because that's why it took him a
while to even get up off the ground yeah
the ref was obviously there's just get
up yeah he was ready to do it he sat
down and i could see he was even like
playing with his eye like showing things
that you don't want to show the ref
you're not sure
exactly if i'm sitting there and i wanna
i wanna be in this fight
i'm giving you the best [ __ ] poker
face i can i weren't going to see
nothing i wouldn't ask you yeah 900 i'm
not going to do something there was a
couple of signs that i seen because i
was right there and i was looking and i
could see that he wanted out i felt like
you know and i knew that fighters
look at
yeah and this is uh again no disrespect
to them no no no not just me like
they're just not like they're never
they're warriors they're going to keep
going and that we all are and that's
just how it is but i felt like they were
like they accepted if the ref stops it
i'm all good with it yeah and i felt
like that and probably in the last two
there was a situation where i've seen
that uh where they're like look if they
stop it whatever but i mean
you know they didn't they didn't get me
out all right [ __ ] it we're gonna have
to get we're gonna have to go do i think
but i've seen that and i felt sort of
bad at this stage because i was leaning
some big shots and he's just too tough
for his own good so i said that's why i
said to him you know are you sure you
want to do it yeah and then like no it
wasn't disrespected at all no i didn't
take it that way at all i think people
that i don't know saw that disrespect
don't know the game but i think you're
sure i didn't know people actually
thought that i don't know maybe they
don't maybe it's my own [ __ ] what i mean
yeah but i yeah i thought it was you
showing your character showing what type
of person you are but and then also
again i know i'm saying how great you
are but
you could have absolutely put on even
worse and you kind of held back to be
honest
when it's uh
it's hard obviously at the start like i
was things will go on a plan but that's
just the type of fighter m i felt like i
could have done more a little bit
earlier but i had my team my coaches uh
you know they were telling me going look
wait because he's still looking for that
shot again that's why he's dangerous
right because he's gonna he'll eat one
and give one and they're always
dangerous and he showed that he's got a
chin he's gonna keep eating them and
he's gonna find me so i had to keep
making him miss i wanted to capitalize
and go in and follow up on things i was
doing but the the team was like not just
yet wait just wait and then i started
getting okay so that's when i really
started picking up but then by that four
finals
that's why i literally said that and i
was like oh i'm gonna
i'm gonna try and finish as quick as i
can and
i went a couple of shots and i think
herb was ready to stop it even like he
was uh one more thing that's it he did a
great job and uh i think he he felt me
because i was even saying but like he's
done man he's done i'm looking at him
he's done i'm saying that i'm sort of
saying it to her but he's done what he's
doing like don't make me go out there
and do this
you look phenomenal to your your coach's
credit too it's you know you look at
that fight i think i don't know he's a
plus 600 something like that
but the reason why that fight's tricky
is a
you know he's a kind of a late
replacement you know shows fight max and
he's the korean zombie man he hits like
a mack truck and he's gonna be dangerous
in those first two rounds yep so why
give him a shot dude well that's it you
know i'm saying like stick and move and
then i knew because we were doing a
couple of fight campaign for it and
watching like oh jesus the speed
difference this is me the longest night
ever in the office for korean zombies
are you just it's not there yeah well i
sort of uh like i've talked about this i
sort of knew
early that all right like it's gonna be
a rough night for him like obviously
they all got the punches chance but i
knew i was on
uh
another level uh when we talked speed
timing distance and all that type of
stuff probably from the first jabi
through and that's really disrespect
yeah because i remember being thrown
right away yeah for him throwing a jab i
remember
the timing of it like the you know he
thought he was in range clearly wasn't i
seen it coming um you know what i mean
just where he thought was the right
opportunity
it was just way off no you're like dude
you're where he knows that yeah and i
just and then again i think it was like
a you know a lot slower i was already
out you know i pretty much had like made
him throw that jab at the same time he
thought i was in i was clearly out so i
sort of got a reading like you even see
me
sort of smile uh then and again it's not
disrespectful it's me actually going
like all right i got this this is this
is this is i don't think that's
disrespectful i think it's more of a
confidence again that was just a smile
to him because he doesn't know what i'm
saying yourself figuring it out
okay
this is this is how it's gonna go yeah
so you destroy the korean zombie no
disrespect you you destroy the korean
zombie
and then now i know you say you want to
be active this year
so as i was driving the studio today i'm
going through some of your options and
you you tell me
where you're at on these so obviously
there's the max hallway fight i think
there's gonna be a fight in australia
hopefully in august or september that'd
be cool you don't have to travel as far
as do work there max comes to your own
backyard it's an easy fight not an easy
fight but i'm saying trip for you
so there's max holloway which and you
tell me if i'm completely foolish yeah
i think
for the legacy of alex the great
i think we need a a [ __ ] stamp on the
max holloway trilogy yeah man look at it
just just to be like it's over man yeah
whatever happened the first two all good
if you beat them decisively you stop
them it's like everybody shut the [ __ ]
up look i'll say i'll tell you where
where i'm at with with this now are you
even thinking about that
no no no no this this is where i'm at
with it see uh before a lot of it was
about proving people wrong and all this
and you know because again there's going
to be a lot of people that are going to
be saying that yeah but i don't care
about that but
now what's the biggest fight
for you like be honest yeah max right
for you for next
year okay yeah well i mean you're
talking about other than that in our
division right in our division that
trilogy with max is what everyone's
talking about most people probably want
obviously in australia be great so
that's why i'd make that decision and
again right now we don't have a cl
anyone else no clear number one until
someone does that people are going to
keep throwing max's name out there so
right now we would want that we would
want our next fight what's going to be
the best pay-per-views what's what does
everyone want
and right now a lot of the a lot of
that's pointed at max and i'm the type
of guy i'll fight anyone that's the
biggest fight and whatnot right now
that's that's what it is we're
supposedly got ortega and air fighting
yeah so if that happens and then say
yeah goes out and wins that obviously
everyone's gonna start screaming his
name yeah but i mean if that doesn't
fight doesn't happen no it's going to be
screaming in the weeks
spot yeah i you know i think if you and
you might be right maybe max is the you
know to me i'd love to see the sites
were great i would you guys fight every
[ __ ] saturday take my money ufc but i
think as far as you when you talk about
big fights mac's a huge name when i see
that trilogy just see what happens there
but then there's also some other names
like henry cejudo talking this smack and
says i'm entering the usada you know
protocol and i'm coming back so that
could be you know you got a guy who's a
double champ he's gonna try and fight
you at 45.
i you know i i don't know
the
you know the the demand there i i feel
like if there was this huge demand this
is no shade on henry's tutor one of the
greatest we've ever seen yeah when the
absolute best
but i feel like he's been asking a fight
for quite some time now
and the demands that he's making i don't
know what they are but i'm sure it's
higher than he's being paid if the value
was there for the ufc it'd be done
we'd have seen it it'd been done so i
don't know if that comes to fruition
it's an option if you ask for it i think
maybe you should be like maybe or just
fight max so you got henry you got max
yep and then you got the outlier who
would be the biggest fight for you conor
mcgregor because you've taken out all
the kings of 45 you have a champion
exactly what and so
but the the caveat with that fight he's
not making 45 you've seen him lately
yeah yeah he's the same size as me no
we're
that's another option too like i will
see what your take is on that but the
lightweight uh
title as well and i've been in a
position i haven't ever mentioned me
moving up or anything like that because
i'm the type of guy you've got to earn
it so we talk i'll go back to henry uh
cehudo in a second but like uh you know
i haven't called i've obviously
mentioned about maybe moving up uh you
know soon in the near future i've always
mentioned that but i've never been like
oh yeah i feel like i'm in a position
where i could at least ask for it well i
feel like now you know three title
defenses uh you know four title fights
uh four wins but three title defenses
and what i've done to the last couple of
guys you know there's a division right
now you know uh
if there's time and i want to be active
and at the time it's not too bad with
the lightweight fight coming up soon do
what do we fit that in but then again
that's where i feel
at least uh that's how i work yeah i
talk about my mentality you know you've
got to earn that [ __ ] and then we talk
about henry cihudo and again i
he uh he deserves a lot because he's
done great things but i mean let's be
real in the featherweight division
it's a different story could he go
straight back into abandoned weight
title probably fly away title probably
100 but i mean it's hard for me to take
that serious
when
like uh let's be real so he would uh
while
i was fine i think when max got injured
yeah he was putting his hand up and then
like he was even given a zombie [ __ ]
yeah for me taking that and things like
that and next minute he's helping him
you know what i mean so it just shows
you a lot of it's going to be
you know what i mean that's his thing
and that's all right and he plays the
game he plays in the game and i don't
mind that he's a great guy he plays
again so that's what people need to
understand why would i do that remember
he was acting like he's adamant for this
title she wasn't even in the testing
pool yeah so you need to wait six months
so you couldn't even do it no it
wouldn't happen it was out of question
but it gets strapped it's impossible but
exactly people don't know the background
that's why i'm gonna wait till
i can see that this is legit
all right
yeah before we even talk have that
proper conversation about it again i
don't mind the dude uh he's uh he can
fight as well but anyway
yeah a whole different base you know
what i mean but uh yeah again he's got
to really really show himself just
getting in the testing pools not enough
like even show show me that you want to
be in this featherweight division yeah
agree um you know when you talk about
lightweight you know i know you've
competed at lightweight back in the day
and even welterweight is that right yeah
away middleweight jesus i'm not defeated
middleweight oh damn yeah you're not
defeated as a boxer too pretty crazy
yeah but um you know i when i walked in
for it i went oh you you're breaking i
thought man like you're not a you know a
tiny small guy
ortega's big but sure on the yeah you're
shorter but you're stocky you know but
you know the lightweights and my one of
my uh coasts on the fight command goes
i'd like to go to lightweight yeah
you're mine man those guys are huge i
know you fought there before but not in
the ufc yeah you're talking about
completely different i don't
i'm not there's no disrespect
it's not in the u.s the ufc is a
different animal it's it's the nfl of
mixed martial arts yep so if you did in
the ufc then yeah cool man yeah you can
find it lightweight
you know we've seen max go up to
lightweight it's just a different
[ __ ] you saw your your close friend
trading partner probably my favorite
fighter on the ufc roster izzy got the
light heavyweight yeah there's a
difference when you go up i'm not saying
you can't complain you meet those guys
that's why i wouldn't say that to you at
all no i'm just saying
you know you haven't appeared there you
get there you know you look at pouring
look at gaity they're bigger dudes yeah
even though so
oliveira's fight at 45. you know so
that's it and may you you make 100
you see a lot of people move up and
the biggest problem
is the strength power side right correct
so this is uh where i'm gonna uh say my
case please um
again most my trainer partners believe
it or not uh
a welterweights and lightweights i don't
train with too many people my my size i
usually train even ufc that's what i
mean it's funny because people are going
oh this is different but a lot of my
trainers are ufc they're in the
lightweights well the world weights
as well so yeah i train with a lot of
these guys
so i do but um
and not just that
um
usually yeah again the strength and the
power so uh that's something that
i have been 214 power pounds
and things like that and just
the strength is isn't a problem for me
yeah obviously people are going to say
size but i mean everyone's taller than
me but i mean when we talk about
strength so if i do wall work wrestling
and all that i am always going to
wrestle
light weights and up you're not going to
see me you know really even when we
another good example usually when we go
to big gyms and you've got
say wall work and they're going to split
them
light weight under light weight up small
guys here they put me on the i usually
with the light weight up or you know
what i mean the welterweights the
middleweights light heavyweights yeah
because when we talk about strength and
obviously the body size and i have that
rest in the background i do more than
hold my own with with the bigger guys
i'm not doing this to my horn i just
want you to i like hearing yeah i want
you to understand like again the
strength is where most people gonna have
a problem but that is something that i
don't think i have problems with the
strength yeah the strength of the light
weight yeah isn't a problem for me yeah
strength wise yes then you're going to
talk about power and then carry you know
how to carry that size exactly
there you go so there there's
izzy a better fighter than yon like
fundamentally 100 that was a white i
think i think he's better fighter
to me that was just clearly a weight
issue he's a better fighter so the
weight there but you know some of these
guys are bigger some are not so i could
see it happening actually brian count on
apology he's not running a [ __ ] light
heavy there's no lightweight there's
always
again a you look at me against the
featherweights and they look a lot a lot
bigger than me as well so i look like a
small small multiple uh lightweight ah
sorry featherweight but uh
the weight it's again i don't know what
it is but i'm a pretty dense dude and uh
pretty heavy huge hands so uh yeah
actually there's a giant hands oh no his
hands are
i
uh
yeah that you know you got a case i
won't harp on again you know i just
going from an outsider's perspective
that's my thing i lightweight when you
when you talk about you know we'll go
eat i'll feed you off this so if you're
going to fight lightweight you're going
to want to eat this food so um i know
where i was going with that oh where the
the weight so yeah so again i might look
smaller but i guarantee you i'm heavier
than uh pretty much all the
featherweights or most of them you're a
dancer i'm a heavy heavy type of guy so
baby rainer well yeah so i will uh we
even did it with uh
with a dan hooker so we we fought on the
same night i think i weighed the same or
if uh i don't know if i was more or the
same as he did when he was at last 55 so
fight though so i'll go in obviously
i don't know how he gets a featherweight
that's just crazy but i mean uh yeah so
i'll get to what close to 170 or 168 or
something like that
oh wow
so i'll put on a fair bit because again
it's a lot of it's water yeah but it's
just the muscle feels the first thing
right now if you find it lightweight so
i apologize yeah no you're right
i said i'm five foot six if i'm lucky
yeah i'm blaming you for thinking that
but uh we'll eat after the training room
one time and i'll change your mind yeah
yeah i'm down for that man let's see
what you got um
you know back in the day used to be the
original thick boy you're online they
said you're 240. and me my boy mark and
mark knows fitness and nutrition joe
rogan started that one two four yeah
maybe maybe me and him because i was
like there's no way he was 240 yeah
you're height were you 240 214 214. yeah
214. in your hotel uh five foot six like
i said i don't even think i am i claim
it yeah i claim five foot six so let's
say five stretched out a bit loose yeah
five six otherwise yeah probably five
probably five five five two fourteen
yeah yeah that's how you that's nuts i
was as wide as i was tall playing rugby
like obviously
yeah yeah but i mean uh just always
thick like you know the legs and
everything was just everything was just
thick why were you so big just
i just luck for her just eating i love
food
yeah i'm going to feed you but just
europeans
yeah man just the [ __ ] loads of burek
and bread and everything you're like a
[ __ ] wild boar out there in the rugby
field just like this little tank yeah
man that was a that hard to tackle when
you're like uh you just lower center of
gravity and just an absolute little ball
yeah man so it was a quick play the
balls that was a sort of my gig just run
the ball go get good meters and uh get a
quick play the ball yeah yeah and
kneecap people take people's knees out
when i'll tackle themselves oh you're a
problem a lot of people hated me that
makes sense well we're not going to get
to 214 but guarantee you're going to
gain a few pounds so let me feed you
guys yeah yeah i couldn't get there
anymore that's something that it's funny
through time i just slowly the
metabolism just got me low and low i
probably couldn't get more than
you know 175 or something like that you
know what i mean like or maybe yeah
someone said for you well you're not
gonna get to 180 this food's not
terrible but it's tasty let me feed you
i love it let's go get it man let's do
it
[Music]
let's take a little break from chatting
with the pound for pound number two man
in the world alexander volkanovsky
because man there's a lot going on in
the nba yep the playoffs has started and
that means they're stepping it up a
level but you're gonna step it up
because if you enjoy the nba you need to
get in on the action with draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner the nba this week new customers
can bet five dollars on any team to win
and get 150 buckaroos in free bets
instantly you win no matter what all
draftking sportsbook customers can also
bet on nba hoops with same game parlays
combine multiple bets from the same game
for a bigger payout the more legs you
add the more money you can win plus each
day of the first round get a risk-free
bet up to ten dollars if your same game
parlay doesn't hit download the
draftking sportsbook app right now use
promo code shobb s-h-a-b bet five
dollars on any nba team to win their
game during the first round of the
playoffs and get 150 dollars in free
bets instantly that's promo code shobb
s-e-h-a-b at draftking sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nba minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply sea show notes for
details now let's get back to the show
[Music]
what kind of food is it would you say is
it uh so it's venezuelan uh i'm
venezuelan colombian
but
venezuelans hold it down on arepas these
are arepas so basically i take a blue
corn masa
and i just like round it out
is that like a bread yeah so the masa is
gonna be think of like a thicker corn
tortilla okay uh and then i split it
down the middle stuff it with cheese
sauce carnitas chicken tinga chicken
salad or just cheese and it's like a
quesadilla i bet that's and then uh i
have uh something special because i hear
we're on a carnivore diet all right i
was gonna cheat for the champ on easter
season i mean it's so cheap but whatever
you got i brought a ribeye
right there oh i love it man but yeah uh
let me show you guys yeah let's do it
they look good yeah so i mean in
tradition um the
chicken salad is probably the most
traditional one um in venezuela it's
called reina pepiada
uh it's basically a avocado based
chicken salad
um
coriander lime
avocado and celery very simple
i use mozzarella cheese on all of them
just because it has a better texture it
melts nicely the saltiness of it
and then the salsa that i make is a
wasakaka which is a venezuelan
based salsa but with my own take on it
pepperoncinis fresnos jalapeno
lots of cilantro avocado
lots it's more acid forward than heat
and then the carnitas i do like a nice
16 18 hours depending on how big it is
um
brace it then i'll recook it with a
secret sauce as well and then once
before i plate it i put it on the
griddle just to have like a nice crispy
outer layer
um
the chicken tinga it's going to be like
a
chipotle style tomato base a little bit
of smoky yeah
um
you can fancy yourself a chef too right
people tell me you like to cook i like
to cook yeah i know i ain't no chef but
i love cooking uh and yeah so have i
even got my own like a cooking channel
so i even do on my youtube social media
i'm just gonna say what's up with the
cooking show from my man here yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna head down like
that yeah man i love it mate i love it
yeah like i said i'm not yeah i'm not
there
or anything like that but i mean if i
flew to australia and you had me over
for dinner what are we eating
with steak steak and chicken wings and
things like that what do you guys call
me out of cold coffee what do you guys
call barbecue out there though isn't it
something different barbecue this is
just barbecue yeah bob act like you're
from [ __ ] iraq i'm like were they
called
yeah the cold barbecue i like cooking
over coal and things over there and
things like that but
steaks what do we call
while we're thinking uh steaks dude uh
ribeye
angus grass fed thank you it's been dry
brine pepper and salt only amazing
just get that going i'm on this weird
carnivores i don't eat red meat
let's see love good see
so while we uh i can show you guys real
quick how
uh one thing i've noted like obviously i
love it i love it here in america but
cheese
cheese cheese everything huh that's why
i love them everything is like oh no
yeah that's why americans are fat dude
yeah i just mean about [ __ ] loads now i
see what you're saying where you're
alluding to yeah
yeah get uh this cheese you treat a lot
of [ __ ] ice cream [ __ ] chopped cheese
cheese on it
just cheese a lot of cheese a lot of
ketchup here and then the portions are
big too yeah man oh that's australia i
mean yeah you know well that's uh there
that's something i remember when i first
came over here my honeymoon with the
with the wife well we call entrees back
home entrees are usually like starters
the starters in a that's something yeah
before yours yeah yeah well uh that's
your main meals here wouldn't it like it
yeah yeah so we got that wrong so i'll
sit there and i'll get a few entrees and
all that and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
that yeah 2 14 again yeah i mean that
was back in the 214 days when i went to
australia i thought was weird is i uh
was on tour there was like five six
years ago i went to bris brisbane
brisbane yeah yeah went to brisbane uh
sydney
perth i forget the other one but um
when i would sit down like they like uh
seafood you call them bugs
seafood yeah it would bounce bound bugs
yeah
even crab and they're like okay
okay yeah is that normal or is this a
weird restaurant oh no i don't want to
eat them i'm thinking it could be like i
said there are a few bugs we've got like
bamboo bugs and there's soda and i know
what you guys would call them here but
um
but they're from the sea but you is is
that a thing in australia like you refer
to crabs as bugs
yeah
yeah no they are like yeah
basically
yeah i know we uh like i said there's a
certain ones that are that i know about
anyway like bargain there's a few of
them like that but
yeah but i mean i i can see it like i do
see bugs on there yeah sometimes yeah
i'm hearing you yeah it made me sick
and then another thing have you had bugs
before rule bugs no never thailand yeah
thailand you go to thailand
i got the crickets and
the cockroaches like what is it
like
huh
locusts there's crickets i know there's
crickets how about that they're like dry
they're not like deep fried yeah there's
a ton of protein in them there's a
movement even here especially with the
hippies like whole foods and [ __ ] here
okay they're like you could get a bag of
uh crickets okay it didn't go well i
think they were they went belly up the
bit there's not something that all day
you know
it was like a dry
nut maybe sort of i'm just gonna eat
nuts though you know exactly
grasshoppers yeah i'll just eat some
[ __ ] chicken for protein but all
right
and they add kangaroo on the menu yeah
yeah man yeah
i don't know you can eat real well with
the coat of arms we've got a kangaroo
and amy and we eat both
we mean total bombs so that's on our
like m like the emblem of australia like
emblem oh you know what i mean yeah yeah
and you can eat both of those
there's a lot of kangaroos in australia
kangaroos are like your dare here right
like theirs are everywhere so you can
just kill them and eat them yeah well
daisy is it we actually get shielded as
well we've got to show those animals man
a lot of animals that'll [ __ ] you up
a lot of small little uh animals that'll
kill you but let's see let's say at your
house where you live if your kids are
playing the backyard and a [ __ ] roux
jumps along can you just take them out
or is there rules against it ah yeah
you're probably in trouble why don't i
live in areas i mean honestly you will
get kangaroos that come like whenever we
go like camping and all that the
kangaroos come right there and they have
attacked people oh you should see the
size of some of them oh some are jacked
they're like literally like close to
your size and they may i remember
because i do a bit of hunting in that as
well but like you see them and they're
like got pecks and biceps other jacks
they're like this and they can fight and
they just look at you like this and
they're just like little stones cancer
oh sorry my language
they're [ __ ] tough what do you hunt
out there
like yeah like uh like pigs and deer and
like just for cool for me you know i
love my fishing and hunting and things
like that good for you man yeah
well that looks good what are we
thinking fellas give me uh where do you
want to try first where are you going uh
rib eye but not bad ribbit's going to be
a little bit it's easter so you know i
get a i got to cheat with the champ here
yeah i can't have you come here and i
eat like an [ __ ]
uh which one do you recommend here
i got carnitas going right now i got a
chicken tinga ready to roll if you guys
want i'll probably do the carnitas the
carnitas yeah no cheese or you want to
oh you put the cheese on there yeah
i'll try the which one was that one
what do you reckon yeah i mean i'm just
trying to you got that one a foot or
maybe yeah mix it up i mean i'm not
going to eat all you can share it okay
we'll do that
you have some ribeye if you want
and the ribeye you know once it's done
i'll have that ready for you guys in a
bit i love my steaks i've done this
carnival i'm down like 18 pounds
yeah i if i if i don't watch my diet i'm
[ __ ]
i'm you back in the day yeah yeah but
not like a fun thing
yeah i'll get to 270 yeah easily man i
gotta watch it and on stage it's not
cool looking i looked like it so what
was the kind of like obviously i've
heard about a fair bit about it's just
fats and protein right no that's keto oh
okay uh
carnivores just make red meat
so like in the morning i'll have like a
rib eye so no salad nothing no no greens
nothing multivitamin
and then i think like strict carnivore
they won't drink like diet coke or
whiskey but [ __ ] that noise i drink a
ton of whiskey ton of diet coke
i might have a heart attack but i'm
losing weight
there you go
that's what i always used to say like
when people like a bit funny with the
the sweeteners you know you get the yeah
diet cokes and sweetness they talk about
oh you'll give you you know cancers are
going okay yeah but i lose the weight
yeah yeah yeah i'll worry about that
later
thanks brother garnitus yeah thank you
sir you got it yeah
that's pretty cool man looks like a
cookie almost like yeah i know right
hey did i hear you did you uh used to
work with scopa do you work with scopa i
work at scope oh you work still there
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah that's my so like
yeah man i uh
stay hustling man i gotta you guys are
staying longer [ __ ]
that's the spot for sure yeah i just got
my whiskey there i just talked to pablo
oh nice yeah
yeah man he's hitting around uh the
ground running right now
with the the rare character
it's this restaurant uh
it's called the scope of italian roots
don't have any signage or anything like
the best bar they have a secret
speakeasy in the back with all like
super exclusive whiskies and drinks they
take your cell phone
and okay can't have cell phones in it
it's so cool man and then to me
that's t-bone in l.a
but it's an italian joint so you
wouldn't think that but the best t-bone
in l.a man and that is uh
venice is uh on the water better yeah
actually we're gonna go there soon yeah
i'm gonna be full now that is
[Music]
hey
[Music]
let's take another little break from
chatting with the champ my boy alex all
the way from australia hopefully you're
enjoying the show but man paying down
debt can be stressful especially when
you need to keep track of multiple
monthly payment dates if you're tired of
juggling due dates all right you're
trying to get your personal loan down
all right that way you'll have just one
due date a month you want
you want to get it down man certainly
have one freaking due date a month
credit karma can help you find the best
option for you credit karma use your
credit data to find loan offers that are
personalized to you so you can have a
better idea of what a loan amount you
can get approved for credit karma will
even show you your chances of approval
so you can choose between loan offers
that you're more likely to get approved
for and apply with more confidence you
got this man comparing loan offers on
credit karma is 100 free won't affect
your credit score don't worry about that
and you could save money fam credit
karma apply with one
credit karma apply with more confidence
today ready to apply cool man head to
creditkarma.com
loan offers to see personalized offers
go to creditkarma.com
loan offers to find the loan for you
that's creditkarma.com
loan offers now let's get back to the
chat
all right my man let's try this uh
venezuelan
taco
oh how do we do this pull it out yeah
it's gonna you know it's gonna get messy
it is
it's real messy
very unique the guy cooks out the back
of an el camino usually i wouldn't trust
it but uh
it's his thing
all right
he's gonna get messy
pretty goddamn good
oh that is good it's nice huh oh yeah
that's very nice thank you i met dude
we would have been walking down the
street we saw a guy cooking tacos out of
the back of his el camino you would
never buy them right ever like you're in
venice beach walking down you see a got
cooking on the back of his [ __ ]
ford focus you wouldn't buy food from
that guy
look at us now dude you're here all the
way from australia yeah eating food out
of the bathroom be honest i've made like
a i probably would i love that is that
your thing
a
especially in thailand i've done a lot
in thailand some of the the cats that
you've seen and you could you look at
the food you're like that's been out for
about 10 hours in this
hot humid weather yeah
you spent a lot of time in uh thailand
could you train out there
uh yeah yeah dude yeah yeah so chaga
muay thai um
it was a big gym there so i remember i
did like tryouts
that's where i sort of uh decided to
take this full-time mma full-time i went
over there and did the tryouts and we've
got a lot of coaches from there that
they've actually got another gym in a
different spot of uh thailand what do
you mean tryouts uh there was like tiger
muay thai tryouts it's called
and what they did they gave gave
scholarships to fighters that were over
there
and there's a lot of them who also dan
hooker was on there oh wow uh
car of france jesus christ yeah man who
also like uh sorry uh ben newman there's
a few of them there's a few guys that
came out there yeah yeah man it was uh
again yeah that was great to us and at
the time you were what were you doing i
was fighting so i was still fighting but
i mean i was early in the career and
that was where i was like
well before then i was concreting and
doing all that as well concreting and
fighting with that was like you know
what i'm going to take this on so i went
over there and got the scholarship did a
heap of training there
and um
yeah that's pretty good is it just stand
up over there no they're not known for
like wrestling well that's right well my
wrestling coach is there like one of my
wrestling coaches like frank hickman the
hickman brothers they're over there and
izzy's like one of these coaches well
andre and frank does uh
a lot of us a lot of our wrestling so
they actually got big mma gyms over
there and that's what a lot of people
think it's just muay thai but they've
got the more tired they've got even k1
kickboxing type stuff and then they've
got heaps of jiu-jitsu oh wow and
wrestling but they've opened another
bang bang tao it's called on the other
side very beachy vibe and i i'm actually
going straight as soon as i get home i'm
home for one day and i go to thailand to
do what they're gonna go there and
because they're opening the gym uh over
their bank tower so
we're gonna go there do a bit of
training and i'm gonna do a seminar over
there and that's cool yeah it'll be cool
how far is that oh the fam's coming
fam's coming yeah so we'll go there a
little bit holiday and and things like
that so it's gonna be good yeah and uh
how far this flight is
nine hours nine hour flight horrible
yeah not too bad
better than uh you know coming over i
think it's 15 hours to all up would have
been close to 20 hours yeah cause you're
going to be comfortable
from here to atlanta atlanta
sydney is that your flight that's you
should have the hubs out of atlanta
dallas yes atlanta nightmare
that's something you've got to
look up as well these videos went viral
now they're trying talking about i try
out so the muay thai
you know muay thais are like under there
like a different breed over there the
way they are and it was uh
bringing the mma into
thailand's like they wanted to teach us
a lesson too so we did uh
all different types of uh sessions i was
wrestling you know grappling and we did
more tried sessions and they [ __ ] us
up
because they bashed the [ __ ] out i got
lucky
but some of the guys i mean like those
guys were stitches like jesus busted
ribs
it went viral yeah
um
yeah he's got a plenty of that footage
and there was a
knuck nuts and they did it like a few
years in a row now it ended up they've
done like three or four different
tryouts and it became a thing where they
were like all right
it was a big hit the first time where we
[ __ ] everyone up so now we're just
going to [ __ ] people up every time
that's the thing now so every time
there's a try they just go all out and i
mean like god and they like this but
they test you they'll be like oh let's
see how their heart goes so
i said yeah like i said those people
getting smashed into
windows smashed over like cages that had
like you know like metal cages and now
you're watching you're like going was
this legit insane crazy i was lucky i'm
seeing the hidden pads because i had
roger huerta oh yeah
yeah
so he felt bad
so i had him so i had him and he felt
bad and i'm just looking over my
shoulder i've seen people getting like
dropped on the floor and [ __ ] i'm like
what's going on here man then the videos
came out and it was just absolutely muay
thai dave bro
yeah you guys are getting [ __ ] up for
you
feel me
fill in the gap for me here so you
you're playing you're playing rugby
right mm-hmm
at what level are we talking about here
like pro like i don't know i don't know
not the highest level summer pro means
what
okay
i was still getting paid but i mean it
was a more like a local you know and i
did like a lot of representatives and
things like but never at the top
so i was like you're a badass seminar
okay i did all right
did you think you could get to the next
level like an actual pro
i did but i mean
my last year
of football had a few fights and i've
always loved martial arts always loved
martial arts and it's bigger you know
maybe in macedonia and greek
i think that's all they ever talked
about you know punch-ons and things like
they love it
so it's always been big it's always
something i wanted to do and
i just thought you know what i i did it
uh stay fit in between
my footy season and i just loved it and
i was like you know what i'm gonna have
a couple of fights so my last year of
football had a few fights
i ended up i think i had like three or
four fights in that one year
i like uh
like i knocked everyone out probably
with not even around so i went pro
without even the round experience oh
yeah so things went really well so i was
like you know what i'm gonna be
disappointed yeah so we went there won
the comp i got a man of the match scored
a trial i'm like you know what i'll
finish this on a good i didn't think i
was going to make it to the top was it
your passion like
is that what you want to do not like it
not like mma is my passion nowhere near
so now like i would have thought maybe
then but i mean compared to mma and how
i am with mma yeah
um nothing never enough yeah like
totally different this is and it wasn't
i was meant to be oh clearly doing what
i'm gonna do clearly it couldn't be
that's good if you weren't meant to do
it you know was it hard for you to leave
that gig because you were doing it for
so long that wasn't it wasn't hard a lot
of people thought i was mad because
again i was pretty handy at football
yeah right so a lot of people are like
oh you're mad why are you doing that so
again i just feel like i can do better
something else like i said if i'm not at
the top that's not good enough for me
yeah
so because again if you haven't made it
by 22
you know you're probably
not going to make it you know it's
probably a lie i'm sure there's people
that proved me wrong you know what i
mean exactly so i started mma at 22
years old
which i mean you know you were started
pretty much i started like yeah 26 yeah
i was playing football okay american
football did you do any other training
before that uh i would do jiu jitsu in
college like just to stay in shape for
the season but no nothing okay yeah
but yeah just so something
yeah i started leighton
i know man just uh again had a few
fights that went well also just keep
doing what i'm doing and thank god you
did look at me exactly thank god i did
you on pound for pound freaking goat
list
i've been talking for a while now so i
know it's hot in here so i'll end this
pretty soon i know you guys got to get
going but
so just going back to things so for you
in a perfect world
obviously you're you know you didn't get
touched this last fight
and you want to fight perfect world how
many times this year three i've been
saying i want three this year so i mean
i haven't been able to be unheard of
though right especially as a champ three
i really do but yeah well that's what i
wanted because they were looking at
going to australia in august
and um i thought you know if i go do
earliest early august and then i can try
and fit one in uh december as well
because it again this uh through the
lockdowns and i've only had like last
year only at the one the year before
that only had the one flight as well
yeah it would be active i want to be
active yeah young forever yeah obviously
i'm still at my peak i've still got
plenty of time but i want to make as
much money as i can while i'm here you
know this legacy that you talk about you
know make that legacy you got to go do
work so i plan on doing plenty of work
this this this year confidence is on a
whole another high and yeah it should be
you know what i mean and just so
give me whoever yeah whatever whatever
fight makes sense i'll get let my team
and ufc have that conversation yep and
i'll just go out there do my thing and
keep racking up these w's and leave that
legacy yeah you're doing the damn thing
man uh all in on this
as far as your your training partner
izzy how do you see it goes down for him
right so you know he the guy that jumped
up to 205.
tough night in the office but you know i
don't think it took any shine off of
them yeah i think you know i think if
they don't they're idiots i think people
should appreciate him taking that risk
which is insane finding guys basically
my size 240 pounds didn't work out for
him all good
goes back destroys that middleweight you
and him are similar though if you look
at the divisions
there's not a lot for him there man
there's really not like he's going to
need some guys to as you said prove
themselves to become contenders they're
trying with the guy who beat him in
glory you know he's a ways to go he okay
yeah exactly yeah he has to get through
yeah they're trying to push him you know
because the narrative there you could
build it oh he beat him in kickboxing
which we know mma is a completely
different animal especially how much
better izzy is now so it's like you know
they hope that kid gets through sean
strickland which is
a very tough fight for him and then you
gotta get through the likes of victoria
and whitaker so that's a ways away so
izzy's kind of the same spot you are
where you know the canon air fight
you know and i like canada a great
fighter i'm just saying as far as
business-wise you know it's you know
it's not going to blow anybody's hair
back and that's not kane is a great
fighter i'm just saying market value
yeah so he's a little bit similar he has
kind of a similar spot yeah you have
more options than he does i should say i
think for him it's tough man he's kind
of he's beat everybody yeah man i think
it's just a time thing as well like you
know what i mean like a you know you
could we could have this conversation
in a month's time and we could there's
no yeah completely different
conversation yeah you're right purely
because of what someone's doing so
that's a that's where i'm at my division
all i can really talk about is my
division my vision these guys there's so
many guys that are fight away they go
out there and have a big win over a top
guy everyone's [ __ ] raving on about
him everyone's screaming their name this
is a guy he's gonna do he's going to
smash alex railroad and they'll shut him
up every time that's what i plan on
doing yeah so uh
it's just a timing thing you know what i
mean and i think that's just a situation
that he sought in as well obviously he's
uh because he's pretty active too so
yeah
stays active he's had a few title fights
in the short time he's been champion so
uh you know that's why right now it
might seem that way obviously ken and
aaron had had a big win yeah great great
i mean again like it's just a yeah
you've got sean strickland a couple of
guys that you know one big win the right
yeah and then then this is a big fight
you know the same assemblers mine like
again yeah rodriguez and ortega i think
that's happening yeah and soon
and um
you know you know that's a big fight
obviously i've just beat ortega so it'd
be hard for them but i mean year wins
that you know you're sure everyone's
going to be yeah you've got yeah you've
got max obviously yeah obviously i'm
talking about the lightweight you've got
these options you've got henry's
pseudo's name getting thrown out there
like again i might take a serious note
there are still there's still options
yeah mcgregor again that would be a
great one so there's still certain
things but i want to be active so it's
just going to be the right right fight
and uh you know again i just had a fight
that sort of had to like because that's
a good idea you had to well who else he
was in yeah you know i wanted to take
someone like zombie off yeah legend of
the the division or that a fight that i
always wanted
tick that off list but i don't want to
have to do that again no i want there to
be a clear guy yeah so we'll just see
what happens well i think either way i
mean you got great options man yeah we
just covered you got i mean four
phenomenal options which is good options
it's just again i want to be active me
being an active might
that's where you're like oh maybe i've
got to wait a couple more more months
than i want to you should yeah because
then i'll have an entire answer you know
what i mean so that's that's the only
situation i'm on because i want to be
active but if it doesn't work out i
can't just have a fight for no just to
do it yeah maybe maybe it does weight
but that's my plans yep perfect world as
you said three fights this year yep well
i hope it happens man i can't thank you
enough for spending your easter sunday
with me and sweating here in the thick
boys studios hopefully you enjoyed your
venezuelan taco also known as gordita
where i come from um but yeah i
appreciate you man i wish you the best
of luck anytime you're in the states you
got to hit me up dude cheers everybody
appreciate you brother thank you thank
you appreciate it
super thick from my wallet to my check i
don't want it if it's skinny but i need
it if it's dead
need a
thick boy
i need everything i get super thick boy